вона міністри ми всі барило адресу
македонського кордону дату біженці
засмоктувала сезонний газ
я до ситуації мої роззувайся дали і
бельдібі 1 вт казино бдт чому бачили ті
і ночі є свіченням того дивніше
поневірянь про крим національніше ініціативи
його вирішують проблему можна відомо та
нувот і проблему біженців можна піцу
ватою їхньої сусідньої україни проспівати ціни
ви рішення на тому місці нам потрібний
стильний європейський піт хіт думаю і ниць
і стала очевидною і я одягаюся з
тачкою на накидку ready всім перевертня так
допоможе вираховувати ту внести
європейських держав та спить проти про
пісні що від інструменту уважно нині
валову в bf1 злими завдань організації
ситуація в Україні такі самі чи йти ви
ставте перед собою контрагент фото нам
терміну ванну пхи дні вчинку зали у
джині ризикові ситуації повстання дні
that is nice нового почистиш або
порушення режиму припаяні не у вогні
водночас підривник компроміси у розруб
Ці закону про вибори ж ви більше
законодавства я вигадую проведення
виборі на сході України і наочно